on
hélas du département étaient construites
entre 1790 et 1793 par jean baptiste de
l'estrac qui était qui a été maire de
saint denis
au départ la villa du département était
habité par des propriétaires terriens
négociant au nom des privés et à partir
de 1860
elle a été achetée par le conseil
général elle est devenue la demeure du
second personnage de la colonie après le
gouverneur le directeur de l'intérieur
l'entrée principale se trouve à l'est
côté rue de paris
on peut découvrir la maison avec son
décor néo classique les piliers les
moulures et des denticules et on
découvre également une toiture à quatre
pans connu sous le nom de toiture à la
française
plusieurs salons de réception que peu le
rez de chaussée de la villa
les trois principaux sont disposés le
long de la barre au sud
il forme une belle enfilade dans
laquelle jeu de miroirs et de vitres
contribuer à démultiplier l'espace le
mobilier de la villa du département est
essentiellement
composé de consoles de fauteuils et de
chaises d'époque napoléon iii nous avons
également
quelques
fauteuils de style louis 15
traditionnellement la président du
conseil général au soin les hôtes du
département
on en sait salon